Wednesday July 8 through Saturday July
Evans we were 11th we're going to be
doing our show from San Diego to
celebrate comic-con we're gonna be there
and this is cool just just for our shows
during comic-con we're bringing back our
conan 360 camera it's a special camera
that will shoot everything in 360
degrees now what a beautiful pan look at
the scenery yeah a Civil War battlefield
camera anyway nobody it's a man it's
actually pretty amazing conan 360 it's
an interactive experience where you the
viewer can watch our show online while
controlling the 360-degree camera that
allows you to look anywhere you want in
theater you can make up your own camera
angles you can look at anything right
during the show it's pretty amazing you
want to look at the guest feet the whole
time look at the guest speed if that's
what you're into then yeah even more
even more exciting and this is true
conan 360 is now for the first time
virtual reality enabled okay you can use
it with these cardboard look at this
cardboard reality headsets right there
I'm not making this up it's the conan
360 experience and all you have to do is
take your smartphone and you open it up
like that and you plunk it in and you
shut it just like that and bang Wow
you're experiencing our show in virtual
reality Wow it's like I'm right next to
you all right next to me all right now
if you want into this amazing cardboard
technology
our channel has officially become a box
of crackerjack dota team koco.com slash
364 chance get your very own free Team
Coco headset and remember put it on me
Conan his nudes editing and remember
okona oh I told you and remember is so
hard remember at Conan 360 with virtual
reality is being made possible thanks to
our pals at AT&T swear thanks
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please